joe and jackson how do you feel about
this storyline
first of all i think it's great i think
it's fun uh
camila's a lot of fun to work with we uh
you know there is a lightness a comedic
kind of tightrope that they're walking
because we're keeping it light but you
feel like
this could go badly at any moment you
know that people very often declare oh i
wanna it's just gonna be
in this case it'll just be sex it'll
just be this don't worry the rest is
covered
and it's not and they could they could
mean it at the time but we're emotional
beings whether we
wear it outside or inside so i think
it's
it's tricky and that makes it fun to
play because there is something at stake
and they're both a bit of a mess they
both have had failure
in their romantic lives and and
rejection i think and insecurity that
comes with that
and that's real everybody can't isn't
this gallant overconfident
person no matter how you what you think
about how they look or their success
we're all insecure um so that's an
interesting thing to play
what is the best case scenario for them
do you think it could potentially turn
serious could one of them get their
heart broken
yet again through this yeah i think they
could
they could uh one or both could get
their heart broken i think there's
total potential there i think they
in some ways it's funny actually i
hadn't thought about it but in some ways
they are each other's pep talk i like
you exactly the way you are
and and that's good enough for me uh and
and sometimes that
that doesn't have that doesn't
necessarily have to be revolutionary in
our life but it just gives us something
solid that we can touch and feel we know
it's there and we can go on about our
day and that's a lot different than
having
you know everything be slippery it's
like a healing thing almost
i i think it's part of it it is
connected to healing we saw baby harriet
i think for the first time slightly
grown up
and she i'm telling you is the most
beautiful child on this planet
are we gonna see more baby harriet
i think we will i think we will we got
some damn cute kids on the show
uh when we do get to see them um and
yeah i hope so i hope so because being a
being a father
being a um a co-parent is a really
important part of jackson's dna
both his joy and his struggles and being
uh
exposed as a as a as a surgeon
it makes it really hard for him to be
present with his kid medically
right so so that um that creates a lot
of frustration and tension that you
might take out elsewhere but
you know as a father myself these are
really and that's
it's not always easy you don't always
feel like you know exactly what you're
doing
um and and that's an important part of
storytelling i think
we talk about hearing it fans including
myself still to this day love japal
i love sarah drew is there a world or is
there more story to tell
with japal and your opinion
yeah i mean i the answer can't be no uh
there's
there's they're incredible um
together they're you know i'm a fan too
she is uh
absolutely one of the most special
people i i've worked with and we spent
we developed those story lines together
with our incredible writers so it'll
always hold a you know
a very real place in my heart and
memories and um
and we stay in contact you know she's
the she's the sweetest so
i would love any opportunity for us to
continue that story because
yeah they are they have it they have it
in droves they have
an ability to communicate and be
vulnerable with each other
and and push each other so even if it
has to just
live in our mind or in some fan fiction
it's uh
i get it i understand it and that's not
always the case i don't think it's out
of the question though because you guys
have brought back patrick dempsey you
guys
brought back tr knight these are strong
arguments let me get my pencil here
yeah let the writers know we need a
jabra
communion even if it's just one episode
we'll do it for good case
remember we had this conversation is
there a more
shocking scene coming up than patrick
dempsey's return
i would think so wow you know it's all
it's all relative for who you
who you're invested in but uh yeah yeah
i'd say so i think it's sandro
fingers crossed this new old spice video
it was hilarious you're gonna stop
taking your shirt off on tv big fella
not for a while i mean we all got to
work but you do
say in the ad you're going to stop
taking your shirt off
on me was that more of a joke or do you
actually
think about that sometimes both it was
it was it was an acknowledgement that
that's been a part you know i'm on
a show where that's part of the bread
and butter of it or it was early on
yeah i'm always encouraging grace to
recruit younger guys so they can take
over that mantle
i can move on um so it was it was taking
a shot at that
but you know in some of the alternative
takes we did i joked about
it's about story what makes sense for
the story you know it's not like
frivolous it makes no sense you know you
take it off your shirt to
wipe something up when there's a napkin
available that's ridiculous
but um but yeah having having some fun
with the you know the reality of things
that that we uh
that we situations we find ourselves in
to uh to uh get the job done
you